pourquoi vous avez fait ce métier
prièement parce que j'avais pas d'utre
métier puis parce que j'aime voyager
j'aime bien la route maintenant ça
devient un peu difficile parce que on
nous embatte de tous les
CIR il est 8h du matin nous sommes à
Roland pont une petite commune de haute
Mar Joël Lefort chauffeur routier prend
connaissance de la cargaison qu'il doit
livrer à Francfort le lendemain matin 26
ans marié père de deux enfants il s'est
levé à 2h ce matin employé par une
entreprise de transport de Strasbourg il
inaugure aujourd'hui son nouveau
semiremorque de 30 tonnes c'est un
routier semblable à beaucoup d'autres il
est payé 3000 francs par mois et fait ce
métier depuis 6
ans
monsieur
ça
bientôtentô
allô bonjour for bon je suis
chargéin matin je
téléphone à CH bon
ou oui aujourd'hui oui voilà allez au
revir ça va ça va enfin pe pas pousser
encore allez au
revoir
bon
[Musique]
je dois charger à volon des briques pour
l'Allemagne je va charger ce matin puis
faire ma Douine l'après-midi et ensuite
livrer demain matin alors quel genre de
chargement vous avez là c'est des
briques en palettes est-ce que ça pose
des problèmes particuliers sur le plan
du chargement ben pour le chargement
c'est assez délicat faut quand même
veiller à ce que ce soit bien chargé
sinon ça risque de les palettes risquent
de tomber quoi puis de casser les
briques hein c'est vous qui êtes
responsable du chargement ah oui oui si
le chargement arrive en PI détaché c'est
à vous qu'on s'en prend hein
est-ce que ça demande une formation
particulière d'être chauffeur de poids
lourdation particulière vous savez ça s
prend ça s'apprend à l'usage il suffit
d'être pris un coup pour pour savoir
hein euh le gars qui a un chargement qui
mal effectué la fois d'après il fait
gaffe hein
et lorsqu'on circule en voiture en
voiture particulière et qu'on voit les
les énormes poids lourds circuler on se
demande un petit peu comment ils
arrivent à manier une telle un tel
tonnage oh ça c'est c'est une question
d'habitude
justeac pas les Ch
[Musique]
plus
le repas c'est un moment important de
votre journée ah bah oui c'est un
meilleur moment là
repos vous conduisez pendant combien
d'heures sur une journée en
moyenne
10h 8h est-ce que c'est pas un peu
difficile pour votre femme finalement de
vou voir partir presque tous les jours
comme ça ah ben
ça si c'est difficile mais pour arriver
à quelque chose faut
travailler de l'argent si on veut elle
l'a accepté facilement ouais enfin au
début c'était un peu dur mais à la fin
on a quand même une vie bon je rentre
tous les samedis vend soir dimanche je
suis quand même
là chose pas rester ené faut bouger un
peu au début
c'est un peu dur au début
mais à la fin on s'y met pourquoi vous
avez fait ce métier prèr parce que j'
pasutre
métier puis parce que j'aime voyager
j'aime bien la route maintenant ça
devent un pe difficile parce que les
partout
contrôleite quelque
chose pasende c'estchargement c'est pas
prêt ou faut attendre on vous dit so
làbas et puisar làure on vous dit
nonsmidi comme
ça c'est brouillard c'est ver
handicap tout à l'heure sur la route on
a l'impression qu' il existait une espr
de solidarité un petit peu entre les
routiers ah ça
toujours on nime pas faire coincer nous
alors si on VO unollè qui peu vite
contrôle
bon fait normal on aima aussi ça reste
pu ça restera
toujours différemment du routier ça je
crois que vous avez aussi des des gars
qui vous laissent tomber mais il a des
actes de nervosité aussi de temps en
temps la fatigue oui ça ça arrive ou
alors ça pas marché la journée ou la
semaine a mal marché on est un peu
énervé on on se dispute c'est fréquent
la fatigue vous la ressentez souvent non
enfin moi non est-ce que vous trouvez
que c'est facile d'être chauffeur
routier en France actuellement ça
devient de plus en plus difficile
pourquoi pourquoi parce
que maintenant il faut déjà passer des
écoles
alors les écoles je sais pas comment
c'est moi maintenant il for des
chauffeurs au bout de 6
mois
suré on devrait quand même les mettre
avec les anciens pour pour leur montrer
les handicaps pe avir sur la
[Musique]
route
les
automobilistes considèrent un peu que
vous êtes une jeune sur la route
qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez j'en pense que c'est pas
tellement normal parce que on est uneigè
eu il se promène nous c'est notre boulot
nous alors j'estime que c qui se promè
il a le temps de il est pas pressé nous
on a quand même un horaire à
[Musique]
respecter quand on arrive au point de
destination on bien cont de dormir pour
pouvoir de
matin touchez-moi
trencul se bien souvent on rencontre
quand même des copains en route on
arrive quand même à à passer des bonnes
petites soirées c'est mon appartement ça
je suis content parce que je suis libre
je fais mon boulot quoi personne me
commande bien entendu il faut que je
sois toujours à l'heure ça c'est normal
mais on est un peu libre quand
même c'est liberté on p cher enfin ça
fait
rien
c'est mon de travail puis c'est mon
appartement qui ve bien c'est ma
vie les problèmes ils existent mais tous
les routiers savent comme Joel Lefort
que lorsque l'on fait ce métier on
l'avant tout dans la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peau